tagli a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fra vj ed oggi siamo
su uno dei videogame più belli più
succulenti di questo nuovo millennio
siamo su home improvvisation ragazzi
anche conosciuto come ikea simulator
mi spiego ragazzi allora innanzitutto
questo videogame ti simula una casa
bisogna montare degli oggetti di
arredamento però come se avessimo
comprato roba da ikea e siamo in
procinto di montare le cose ci tengo a
dire prima di cominciare che voi potete
utilizzare questo video come tutorial
del caso doveste montare qualcosa ha
comprato dai che ha un insomma qualcosa
di difficile da montare guardate questo
video e capite questa è la scatola
abbiamo aperto subito il nostro tavolino
bourque che si chiamava puorc per
montare il tavolino prima cosa che
bisogna fare e afferrare saldamente la
parte del tavolo dopo di che i ragazzi
si prendono i pezzi del tavolo e si
inseriscono nelle apposite cose tipo
come si fa e il sesso però ecco così
perfetto è partita una musica figlia ho
inserito il primo giuggiolo ed è partito
uno io sto scherzando stato fermo dritto
dritto il più bravo perfetto
meravigliosa quanto storta la gamba
ancora uno e siamo abbiamo vinto non ci
posso credere non ho montato il primo
mobile della mia vita ragazzi non sono
mai riuscito è un gran giorno questo lo
mettiamo ovviamente davanti alla porta
di entrata del soggiorno essendo next
box ma mi dai proprio tutti i prezzi a
posso cambiare il nome del tavolo tavolo
j tribute treppiede allora la prossima
dalla cosa da montare e questa lampada
sta diventando sempre più difficile
perché c'è anche questo pezzetto che di
norma sembra una supposta con dei
marshmallow attaccati sopra vabbè prima
cosa attacchiamo la supposta con i
marshmallow all'ala perfetto attenzione
che se tenete la lampada troppo sul
tappeto potrebbe andare a fuoco il
tappeto stesso quindi e par che va no no
no cazzo fai al divano avap eni
marshmellow sono dei punti di
congiunzione non ho ben capito come
dovrebbe essere montata questa cosa però
va bene ok ma la madonna che musica di
sottofondo triste ha fatto fa chi è
forse cazzo è sta roba questa tavola
fnora la larghezza non si è rotto va
bene è fatta apposta per essere
incastrata nelle cose tipo last da scala
ecco a posto questa è la lampada moderna
che non capite un cazzo non capite
montata in modo figo per non essere
troppo standard mi vedi ingegnere per
caso vediamo di calmarci piano come si
fa a far star male cos'è ma nelle da me
le date le istruzioni per cortesia cosa
sto montando non ho neanche capito
credo che alla fine uscirà fuori un
oggetto e capiremo che cosa stiamo
montando ma solo alla fine le perfetto
dovremmo esserci raga ok adesso sì che
si capisce che cos'è ovviamente questo
attaccapanni e un attaccapanni moderno
il prossimo ragazzi è un'evidente
modello di sedia tipo questa che ho io
che si chiama b class bene oddio ci un
cuscino paranormale perfetto
meraviglioso così bellissimo
o che minchia mangia in teoria lo
schienale che prova va beh è una e una
sedia per nani ma c'è il catalogo che
figo quindi posso scegliere cosa montare
tipo un ragno bello fantastico woodstock
board mi sono cagato addosso come cazzo
ci sei finita lì sopra quanto può essere
storta st seriani al prossimo che è
niente di cui preoccuparsi
parte il fatto che si sono già mischiati
pezzi quindi iniziamo che è un piacere
il primo pezzo ragazzi triangolare
simbolo massone ammontato nel secondo
piolo che questo qui il secondo pezzo
che è sempre massone va montato nel
primo pezzo del polo storto arrivati a
questo punto ragazzi avremo non uno ma
ben due simboli massonici nella trave di
legno era giusto laila stai facendo
parquet ma non così va bene lo fa niente
anta massoneria in un solo scaffale
manca l'ultimo pezzo che questo qua che
dovrebbe essere qui perfetto fa chi era
e meraviglioso il fatto che mele da
giuste me la cosa giusta come se ne
fosse giusto così provare che la bella
mensola fantastico ho chiuso sbloccato
ho sbloccato un'altra stanza che sono
contento solo per il fatto che adesso
più spazio per lavorare sono
contentissimo prima cosa da fare in
questa bellissima stanza e palpare era
bella signora questa è la posso spostare
proprio adesso fa vige vi insegna a
giocare a scacchi credo che questi buchi
vanno infilati nei piccoli penney
intanto la madre natura ci ha sempre
insegnato così sapete che mi irrita il
cazzo sta musica di sottofondo spaccare
tutto
non lo so perché mi dà
però non mi prendere troppo alla lettera
e zia ci credete che questo qua credo di
farlo bene per la prima volta nella vita
farò un oggetto come si deve lo giuro è
un'occasione più unica che rara non vi
perdete questo momento ragazzi non ne
vedrete mai uno simile credo che la
prima volta nella vita che qualcuno
riesce a montare un oggetto come deve
essere montato effettivamente io non è
che fico i pip in pezzettini nel tavolo
ficoltà volo nei pezzettini contrario e
adesso tutto sto popò di roba va ficcato
qua mi chiama sta uscendo veramente raga
non ci posso credere sono emozionato non
ci posso credere
fermi fermi fermi o cazzo perché perché
mi hai fatto questo va bene va bene come
tavolino è un po moderno basta non
mettere la roba nel primo ripiano negli
altri va bene come si coccola il prezzo
di sotto a no che ho capito per mi fai
feci sono questo va qua è perfetto fatto
una sedia in 2d sedia in 2d ma i favi j
lanciamo questa cosa sul mercato vediamo
se funziona se io prendo l'altro pezzo e
lo metto qua diventa una sedia in 3d fa
chi è a ragazzi
manca solo lo schienale dove vai dove mi
servi o meraviglioso che orgasmo di
sedia prossimo ragazza prossimo
bellissimo non ha idea di che cosa sia
ma va bene è un letto
ok ma cos'è sta roba non è un divano
sarà vera croci postare direttamente
gesù qua l'ultimo pezzo dovrebbe essere
in teoria in teoria e dico che non lo so
questo grazie grazie mi ha appena detto
in svedese il tizio che ho fatto un gran
lavoro grazie fratello adesso questo va
incastrato dentro lo scaffale fatela
metterà me una cazzo di canzone decente
perché non posso siete carichi ragazzi
siete pronti
mentre molti immobili che lampada vacche
lampada post moderna che poi non è
neanche troppo male ragazzo mi sono
peggio non sta in piedi però per quello
potrebbe essere un problema
se faccio come sasha spacco piano casa
si spacca st eccolo lì va bene ragazzi
direi che va bene così spero che la vita
vi sia piaciuto spero che abbiate
imparato come montare immobili
ricordatevi che nel caso aveste bisogno
di un tutorial potete tranquillamente
utilizzare questo video che credo sia
esauriente 100.000 like e vi insegnerò
anche a montare altre cose ha già pace
di facebook e come votare tiziana sensi
discreti di euro prossimo video bella
ragazzi comunque intendevo montare i
video